والشهر الاسد يحط ريحانه بالعاصمه الروسيه
موسكو ويصافح من جديد ابرز حلفائه الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين زياره كانت الاولى
من نوعها للاسد خارج الشرق الاوسط بعد
زلزال الذي هز سوريا وتركيا زياره تحمل
اكثر من رساله في ظل التطورات الاخيره
التي عرفها شار السوري بعد الكارثه صحيفه
لوفي سلطت الضوء على المكاسب التي حققها
الاسد بعد زلزال وذلك من خلال اعتماده على
دبلوماسيه الكوارث فحسب
نجح في توظيف الزلزال لكسر حزلته
الاقليميه
روسيا بدورها لا تزال تحاول جاهده نحو
الدفع من اجل كسر العزل على النظام السوري
وموسكو تقوم بمحاولات جاده من اجل الدفع
نحو تطبيع العلاقات بين دمشق وانقره من
خلال ترتيب لقاءات رسميه تمهيديه بين
الجانبين ايضا الاستقبال الرسمي الذي حظي
به الاسد لدى وصوله الى موسكو يعد دليلا
على رغبه روسيا في اضافه شرعيه اكبر على
النظام السوري وكان بشار الاسد قد قام
مؤخرا بزياره رسميه الى سلطنه عمان كما ان
وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح شفقي حتى
الرحاله في دمشق نهايه فبراير الماضي في
اول زياره لمسؤول مصري رفيع الى سوريا منذ
بدء الحرب في البلاد سنه 2011